-Unfortunately for you,
you also confess
to the crime of fraud...
to being a charlatan...
a purveyor of lies
and narcotics.
You're an animal who preys
on the despair of the poor...
and who abuses
their trust in you
for your own ill-gotten gains.
You are confessing
to those crimes, are you not?
-Well, damn.
When you put it like that...
[ Laughter ]
-Welcome back.
We're here with James McAvoy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a clip
from "The Book of Clarence."
This looks like a grand-scale
biblical epic.
-You've got a biblical epic
on your hands.
-But it's also very funny.
It's sort of a comedic
biblical epic.
-It is funny.
It's heartfelt. It's full of...
It's, dare I say it,
it's full of faith.
Um, and it is just wild.
That director, Jeymes Samuel,
man, he is special.
He's something different.
-You are playing
Pontius Pilate in this role.
You are --
You were raised Catholic.
Is this a character
that you put a lot of thought
into over the years?
-Finally,
they've let me play a Catholic.
[ Laughter ]
All I wanted to do
was play a Catholic.
[ Laughter ]
But after the actions
of the Catholic Church
in the last few years,
it wasn't fashionable.
Um...
[ Laughter ]
Thank you for --
Thank you for this secondary
roll-over laugh.
Those four people...
-It's also
their first show of 2024.
It's like everybody's
getting back into shape.
-You guys don't
get invited back.
Um, yeah. You're in trouble now.
I'm not. I hope.
Um, yeah,
I was brought up a Catholic.
Was it fun to play a Catholic?
Yeah, it was great.
And, no, I didn't
play a Catholic,
but I was in a biblical epic.
-And you got to wear, uh...
You made a choice.
You made a choice
for Pontius Pilate,
which we saw in the clip,
which was guyliner.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, a very heavily
eyelined Pontius Pilate.
-Yeah.
So, he's -- he's kind of
like -- He used to be a soldier.
Now he's a bureaucrat, right?
That's what I felt about him.
And I thought,
"How do I make it look
like he would rather be
anywhere else?"
And I was like, "Guyliner."
[ Laughter ]
Honestly,
because I was thinking,
like, the Romans,
they were kind of...
they were kind of experimental.
-Yeah.
They were having
a grand old time.
They were having a grand
old time -- orgies --
[ Laughter ]
...and I was like --
-First footing in Rome...
-First footing.
-...totally different.
-[ Laughs ]
-First footing in a toga,
it can get messy.
Um, and I was just thinking
that maybe if I've got guyliner,
it would just look like
I'd rather be in an orgy
than dealing with a messiah.
-Yeah.
And so LaKeith Stanfield, uh,
he is someone who has
sort of noticed how much
attention Jesus is getting.
-Yeah.
-Basically, he's trying
to be another messiah.
-Yeah.
He looks at Jesus as a guy
who's on the make.
He doesn't believe,
he has no faith,
and he doesn't believe in God.
So he's like, "This guy is doing
great with a scheme.
So I'm going to -- I want to be
like that in five years.
I want to be like that now."
So he's like, "I'm gonna
just do what Jesus is doing."
So all the stuff that happens
to Jesus happens to him.
LaKeith is brilliant
in this film.
He is an amazing actor,
and he's so good.
-He is a really --
He's a really wonderful actor
and it is such a fun idea
for a film.
And you --
Is it true that you did
consider life in the clergy
before you found
your way to this?
-Yeah.
Look, I really wanted to travel,
and I did consider, um,
becoming a missionary.
And then I also realized
that I would have to be celibate
if I became a priest,
and I was just starting to get
luck with the opposite sex,
and I thought,
"I can't do that."
So I decided to join
the Navy instead.
And then I didn't join the Navy,
and I became an actor, and...
[ Laughter ]
And that's my life.
-[ Laughs ]
Well, we're very lucky
to have a front-row seat for it.
Thanks for being here, man.
-Thank you. Cheers, man.
-What a pleasure.
-Thank you.
-James McAvoy, everybody!
First guest of 2024!
"The Book of Clarence"
is in theaters January 12th.
We'll be right back
with Rachel Dratch.